we all want to know Garth so tell me
[ __ ]
[Music]
today's episode of answer the internet
is brought to you by curve stick around
to the end for more details I am
Christina p and I'm here to answer the
internet
ready here we go
if you could uh if you could get access
to one person's phone and look at all
their [ __ ] who would it be
done with my husband's
next question
but I don't because I'm a nice lady and
I don't want to know anything but I
would like to know what porn he looks at
because I feel like I've respected that
boundary and I shouldn't
if you were murdered who would
be the most likely suspect again my
husband Tom segurat next question
all right speaking of foreign okay if
you had to watch one category of porn
for the rest of your life what would it
be oh this is so [ __ ] easy okay
um I would choose orgy porn because that
way it's like a buffet of human stuff so
you could look at one side of the room
if I choose one genre for the rest of my
life and then like oh look there's
there's like a guy and a girl and
there's a girl and a girl and there's
whatever going on it's everything
Smorgasbord a little bit of everything
what what uh what do you think Tom's
answer for that would be oh my God
I bet Tom is into like
old guy young girl I want to say or like
middle-aged dad and like hot babysitter
yeah like uh I'm just gonna drive the
babysitter home and she's like oh thank
you Mr Sticker I love your latest
special and he's like prove it and then
yeah
something like that comedy groupie porn
would you rather be 15 or 50 for the
rest of your life oh my god oh 50. hands
down because I I'm getting close to 50
and it's not as awful
as I thought it would be also 50 rich is
a lot different
I actually think I'd rather be my hair's
all [ __ ] up well like even younger
when like life really what what really
you're just like riding your bike and
like playing video games and going to
the pool in the summer and you don't
give a [ __ ] about anything oh wow you
had a good childhood yeah yeah I wanted
out by 15.
streets bro I was like get me out of
here I hated 50. I smoked heroin at 15
so I take 50. if you got a one-time pass
to do whatever you wanted what crime
as you commit oh man this one's so easy
for me I wouldn't want to steal stuff
because that's boring I would murder
somebody
definitely with a knife and I would uh I
would stab them on their chest like I
could feel the rib cage break and split
um I don't know who I'd hate that much
though like I think killing somebody's
got to feel like the best with your bare
hands right
what would you trade a three-year-old
baby for what
what who wants a three-year-old they're
terrible I would trade a three-year-old
baby for a nice tuna melt from a Jewish
deli in New York because we don't have
Jewish delis in Austin if you could [ __ ]
anyone you wanted but they'd die
immediately after who would you pick oh
that's such a good one can I time travel
sure [ __ ] it I would [ __ ] Hitler because
anybody hot I don't want them like I
don't want Ryan Gosling to die right
right you got to think of someone who's
like a piece of [ __ ] what about Putin
I'd [ __ ] Putin he's horrible but he's
going to be an easy lay
I don't know do you think Putin's harder
easy to bang because he's so old she
probably has neuropathy issues recently
be a good bang very virile masculine
poutine what's one thing Tom could do
that would make you consider killing him
oh fake and easy and I tell him this all
the time I'm like if you bang another
female comic I'll [ __ ] murder you
okay [ __ ] specifically comic oh my
God like if he bangs anyone like a
groupie or something like I would murder
him but if he banged a female comic I'll
[ __ ] uh rip his dick off and I'd stab
him in the [ __ ] chest
if I wouldn't go to jail if you could
live anyone's life in their body who
would you be oh I love this question
you know what's funny I like my life my
life turned out pretty great but if I
had to choose somebody else right now
living I'm obsessed with Isabella
rossolini she was her mother was Ingrid
Bergman she was a Lancome model and now
she lives on a farm on Long Island and
she's 71 and she's like look at my
chickens I'm hatching baby chickens
today and my goats are following me and
she's just so like she's had done it all
she's been a model she's been a movie
star and now she has a farm and I think
that's just lovely she's good priorities
in life yeah it is is jerking off to
webcam girls cheating yes hard yes next
question a webcam girl because can't you
interact with them yeah that's cheater
on okay okay what if it's you what if
like you're not the one interacting with
it like it's a live thing but like you
know someone else is paying them and
interacting with them and you're sitting
there as long as you can't communicate
with them and they can't communicate
with you how long could you last on the
Run on after robbing a bank [ __ ]
forever because yeah right yeah right
yeah you know why I'll tell you why man
because I have escaped DNA my parents
escaped communism in 1969 my parents
fled from communist [ __ ] Hungary and
lived in Italy and lived in Canada
before we came to the U.S so I've got
that DNA in me bro I I bet you because
every time I watch a movie where they
have to when they're like I'm gonna go
to jail like no you don't you can
[ __ ] live in Mexico bro like you
could go anywhere
get your cash bro you get your cash
I will get it I will get it I would
Charter a jet
with a [ __ ] duffel bag of cash and
have that that offshore Swiss whatever
yeah what is it a Swiss bank account
where they can't be traced or whatever
in the Bahamas that's where I'd go the
Cayman Slater and we know what I say my
plan now I can't do it who is your unite
white who's your white whale podcast
guest oh meaning like the one you want
the most is this a Moby Dick reference a
book I never read
um it might be white whale it's a pretty
common phrase you ever heard that no
because I'm not American I swear I swear
you're stupid and stupid and I grew up
with foreigners who never taught me
normal things okay
okay hold on hold on I think Elon Musk
would be pretty great the [ __ ] who
would you want to do that the heavy
segment with oh that'd be fun like
you're really upset really torture
somebody
Brad Pitt Brad Pitt but let me think who
I want because I like weirdos I don't
like normal gas you ask me I want like
the guy that jerks off in four strokes
do you know what I mean like if you feel
like ymh I would like to find the four
strokes guy and I would like to have him
on your mom's house I think that would
be because like celebrities okay but the
guy that can come in four strokes and
has no neuropathy issues
and can smoke meth and his brother
doesn't believe him but he does now like
that kind of [ __ ] that's the one that's
the white the white one would you rather
have no music for the rest of your life
oh my God or have all music be sung by
your significant other
[ __ ] oh I love music so much I would if
I have to go between no music and Tom
singing it I would choose Tom singing it
and I like stupid [ __ ] like I like goth
early 80s goth music so he's gonna have
to learn the Bauhaus catalog
if you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
Aliens who would it be Joe Rogan
obviously
I do feel like you
oh yeah yeah like you don't want
somebody who's just all nerd and no
sociability I feel like
I feel like Joe represents such a big
chunk of the population he's pretty
indicative and he's way into them oh
what's the grossest thing Tom does that
you find attractive oh God he's so
disgusting
you know he
good like it's pretty good for you he's
had a nice glow up he was way nicer I
know got in shape and dresses nicer and
[ __ ] it's like I know do you know how
much I love him like I loved him but he
wasn't
you know yeah when he was just like
sleeping on a mattress like a dog
and now yeah prom does this thing which
is really cute where he can scratch his
armpit you know most people use the
opposite yeah he does this yeah and
he'll go
but he does it like a skin on skin but
he's always shirtless when he does it
and he'll be watching football and he'll
unconsciously go
and I know the sound so well and it's
cute and endearing because he's so
unself-aware when he does it and I it's
so gross because I'm like I know that
hand's going to be on my face deodorant
yes flecks of
deodorant we are on our way for our West
Coast tour for KFC radio I never leave
home without my curve card we're going
to be flying we're going to be dining
we're going to be spending money I need
my curved card to make sure I keep track
of all my expenses now you can even time
travel with Kern what does that mean it
means that I can take a prior expense
and move it to my credit card to free up
cash to pay for a new expense that I
didn't know I was gonna have that's the
kind of stuff that curb lets you do on
top of getting free curb cash and double
your points go to curb.com Barstool to
download the app today and get 20 of
free curved cash herb is brought to you
by hatch Bank in terms of conditions
apply where do you think Garth Brooks
hides his body foreign
that's the real question isn't it
internet we all want to know Garth so
tell me
I know so [ __ ] good it's mated until
like newspapers and stuff you know what
I think he really does hide them
on his Ranch because he's got he's got a
lot of acres and can I tell you because
we looked at a place in Texas with like
acreage and you go well why would you
want that why would you want that it's
just trees and snakes and unbridled land
there's [ __ ] on there there's only
one reason
fine he's [ __ ]
yeah thank you
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out